make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and as
i was sitting here thinking about this i
was like you know i could do the aliens
comics but the more i think about this
because i asked you guys a question
previously like what stories i hadn't
finished that you guys wanted me to
finish up and
people said dark side war they were like
finnish dark side work here's the thing
i made dark side war back when my video
sucked and so i was like you know what
if we're gonna finish it we might as
well remaster it right so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna remaster dark
side war and i promise this one won't
suck as much as the last one did
so here's the thing to understand about
dark side war dark side war was the
event that led into dc rebirth and it
was basically dc kind of
you know pruning a lot of the things and
adjusting a lot of the things and
setting the stage for a lot of things
one of the other important concepts to
understand here with dark side war
is that some of the stuff that we see
does not apply anymore did a lot of this
not really a lot but some of it was
changed
during the events of dark knight's medal
and death metal and
scott snyder's justice league run so uh
i will go ahead and make sure that we
know what information stays what
information goes
as we're going through this story but
when it comes to dark side world we're
initially going to start with issue
number 40. now this whole video is going
to be issues
40 through 45 for those of you guys who
want to keep track or buy it online or
something like that it's called dark
side war act 1.
for issue number 40 there's not really a
whole lot that matters here i mean we're
kind of given a little bit of
information but it's things that you
know things we already know for the most
part for example
uh scot-free is the son of high father
on new genesis
and for example that like metron
brokered a piece between new genesis and
the planet apocalypse where darkseid
resides different things like that you
know just just that kind of situation
what does matter and really the big
takeaway that came from issue number 40
from the very beginnings of all this
is the anti-monitor mobius now initially
we didn't know the anti-monitor had a
name and in fact we didn't even really
know that he had any kind of personality
or anything
all we really knew about the
anti-monitor is what we got in the
events of crisis on infinite earth and
infinite crisis when the anti-monitor
was responsible for the destruction of
the multiverse and then we returned
during the events of infinite crisis and
sinestro core war when he joined the
forces of sinestro but this was a huge
change a huge departure for his
character because one it's established
his name is mobius
and two he was the reason for the
destruction of the earth three universe
now as part of the lead
up to the events of darkseid war you got
a story called forever evil and forever
evil was basically this story where the
crime syndicate of america which was an
alternate reality version of the justice
league where all the heroes are bad guys
where they had basically fled their
universe and showed up in the main dc
universe that was the whole basis behind
the forever evil event we didn't really
know exactly why that happened and when
dark side war took place when that
started up this gave us the explanation
that in effect uh mobius had shown up to
the earth 3 universe and basically
eradicated all the life on that on that
world and then in turn had absorbed all
of his energies into himself
and so the big thing that kind of comes
out of this and and kind of what we're
told here
when metron encounters mobius and a
really good way to view metron is kind
of like the dc universe version of the
watcher to a degree i mean he's not as
powerful as like the watcher in marvel
and even in and of himself
he's not wildly capable uh he is and so
far is the fact that he's a new god so
like
you know he's stronger than your average
bear but uh and you know with the chair
that he has the the mobius chair
that's what makes him so capable is
because the person who sits in the
mobius chair
has all knowledge of everything that's
currently going on in the universe and
everything that has happened in the
universe and so one of the things that
happens is that when metron
encounters and really comes across
mobius he initially tells them like
you can't do this right like i know what
it is that you're shooting for i know
what it is that you're trying to do
do not do this because i know what fate
awaits you you're going to call down the
power of dark side
and dark side is going to lead to your
destruction not only that the war that
you're trying to instigate here between
yourself and dark side
this is going to lead to the end of the
of of the universe it's going to lead to
the end of reality and one of the things
that's kind of hit on here in dark side
war is that
because we got events like crisis on
invented earth and
zero hour crisis in time and infinite
crisis and final crisis and
even the main new 52 event because of
the fact that we got so many different
crisis events that basically rewrote the
universe
if another one were to happen the the
universe and even the multiverse
wouldn't be able to survive it would all
just basically be destroyed there'd be
no way to save it because one thing to
understand is that in the previous
crisis events
it was more or less restructuring
reality is really what it was it was
like remodeling your home
what metron's talking about here is that
if another crisis were to happen it'd be
like blowing your home up
right that's more or less what he's what
he's offering here what he's saying here
at the end of the day though mobius
doesn't care right he's looking to
attain the power
really attain a way to kind of go back
to the way he was before to undo this
hellish life that he's living now we are
given a bit of an explanation and really
kind of a lot of an explanation
in terms of why he is the way he is uh
what it is that powers him and
his whole motivation behind this war but
we don't find out until the end so
uh it kind of sucks it kind of sucks in
that way
but one of the things is that where
metron initially tries to stop him
ultimately he's overpowered by mobius
and mobius basically says like i want a
war with darkseid that's what i'm
shooting for
and so the big thing that the other big
thing that came out of this is that
following metron being overpowered you
end up having the appearance of this
kind of mystery woman that seems to be
operating
you know along the lines of mobius
helping him to achieve this goal now
that's all basically prelude stuff the
meat and potatoes this picks up when you
have a woman who shows up in her
apartment by the name of marina black uh
for those of you guys who are also
wondering this art is by a guy named
jason favac it is amazing isn't it but
kanto is basically there along with
lashina waiting for this woman to get
home
they ask her are you marina black and
when she responds like yeah but like
where's my husband at they kill her
now this turns out that it's not the
marina black they're hunting for and
they're actually looking for a very
particular woman
it's almost like terminator right you
know he's just looking for a very
particular woman
and it makes sense to just go through
and kill every version they find until
they ultimately kill the one they're
looking for now a little bit of
explanation here
uh lashina is part of a group called the
furies and kanto is an assassin
for darkseid uh the furies are almost
like darkseid's kind of
elite guard composed almost entirely of
women there are men who are furious but
you don't really see them all that often
uh but lucina is one of the best she's
not the absolute best
but she's one of the best but what this
does is it switches over to a guy by the
name of scot-free now scot-free
is also known as mr miracle and kind of
referencing our discussion
on metron brokering peace between
apocalypse and new genesis
because they kind of represent the idea
of like absolute good and absolute evil
even though
new genesis kind of stretches the limits
of credulity when it comes to truly
being good
uh what this basically meant was that
they had to switch sons right so uh the
son of darkseid went over to
uh went over to new genesis and his name
is orion the son of high father who was
named scot-free was sent to apocalypse
now unlike orion who lived on new
genesis who lived a pretty great life
and ultimately became a hero
scot-free was basically thrown into the
slave pits by by darkseid and just left
there
the result is it became a master at
being able to pick all manner of locks
and so that's why he's called mr miracle
he's kind of the escape artist of the dc
universe because there's no lock in the
universe that he cannot pick
but the thing here is that him kind of
going around and bouncing around and
sort of being free to a degree he's
ultimately hunting for what it is that
darkseid's trying to achieve because
word has reached his ears the dark side
is shooting for a particular goal and so
the result of this is that once he ends
up grabbing one of the mother boxes and
it kind of spills the beans on what dark
side's shooting for he begins to panic
right he's kind of like okay
like this can't be possible something
has to be done right so a lot of mystery
going on in this this first little
tidbit here now
from there we switch over to an
investigation that's taking place with
the justice league this is not
overly important it kind of is to a
degree because it sort of furthers the
story a little bit but it's a little
more character development than anything
else this first part is really just kind
of designed to show us
what the different people are doing at
different points in time uh but we do
have jessica cruz here and for those of
you guys who are not familiar with
jessica cruz
she was introduced as part of the
forever evil event and then just sort of
kept moving forward with dc comics and
the idea is that her whole writing
experience or the whole idea behind
creating her character
is that she's someone who's kind of
riddled with anxiety and depression and
so in a lot of ways it seemed to sort of
mirror to a degree the struggle of jeff
johns and even more so the struggle of
sam humphries a writer who was who's
amazing in everything he touches but the
idea is that from the earth 3 syndicate
you had their version of the green
lantern called power ring unlike hal
jordan in the main dc universe power
ring was just a coward
but the ring itself would constantly
talk to him and influence him now for
those of you guys who follow the green
lantern mythos you guys know
it was essentially both doom if you
don't know what that means you can find
out more about that in the green lantern
playlist that we have
but in essence the ring of jessica cruz
is possessed by a malevolent entity is
really all you need to know but she was
very much
just kind of controlled by her anxiety
to a degree right it dominated every
facet of her life
her evolution as power ring in dc comics
was designed to show
or really kind of represent the struggle
of a person overcoming their anxiety
things like that becoming a much
stronger person
and finding their inner strength right
so that's why she's here it's the reason
why if you've never heard of her as a
green lantern it's because at the time
this story was written she was
exceedingly new
but again there's not a whole lot doing
here in this this early tidbit right
just
a few things here and there some some
you know little indications
of what people are doing and and so on
and so forth the big thing about this
is that when you have the justice league
conducting their investigation
that because cyborg is a living computer
and can tap into the various
intelligence satellites and things like
that he begins to pick up on a pattern
and what he starts to realize is that
there have been these various murders
taking place across the united states
basically the murders of women named
marina black and so because that he
realized somebody's tracking her down
they're looking for a very particular
person who that person is the justice
league doesn't know
but in the middle of all this suddenly
out of nowhere hands just like emerge
from the mouth of barry allen
and like this girl just pulls herself
out right this mystery girl working for
darkseid
just pulls herself out now the reality
is we know this girl is grail right we
we know that
the nature of our character kind of
looking at this in hindsight but
suspension of disbelief let's imagine
that we're five or six years ago in dc
comics and we don't know
the cool thing is that as soon as she
emerges she immediately overpowers the
justice league like
right off the bat right batman cyborg
all these guys they're all
immediately overpowered by this girl
even shazam falls before the power of
the squirrel now she doesn't
kill them all she just overpowers them
the crazy thing is that of course
wonder woman jumps into the fray and
wonder woman you know this this girl
basically reveals that she's of amazon
blood so she in some form or fashion
hails from themyscira which is kind of a
crazy thing it's not uncommon it's not
the first
time that we've seen some mystery woman
out there in the dc universe who hails
from themyscira who we've never heard of
before
dc's done that like two or three times
before usually it's only confined to the
wonder woman mythos
sometimes it's the justice league as a
whole but the important thing is that
following that while while she basically
incapacitates
the entirety of the justice league we
switch over to superman and lex luthor
now superman is currently attending with
lex
because for the most part lex luthor is
currently a good guy and the reason why
is because of the events of forever evil
the following the forever evil story
that lex luthor had kind of reworked
himself and when the heroes were
incapacitated
during that event by the crime syndicate
lex luthor led a contingent of villains
and kind of reformed them
into becoming heroes in order to save
the world following that some of the
villains went
back to being villains most of them
stayed heroes that's why you have
captain cold here different things like
that but the reason why superman lex
luthor are together here is because of
the fact that there is a former villain
or at least a villain at one time
named neutron who's currently lost his
powers now that goes into the amazon
event it's not overly important for our
discussion here the important thing is
that neutron has the ability to absorb
like nuclear radiation
to use it for his own ends the good
thing about this is that when you have
the ability to do that you can achieve
all kinds of stuff
flight super strength different things
like that the downside is that when your
body loses the power to process nuclear
radiation it turns into cancer and so
because of that neutron's basically
dying
now of course superman pulls a little
bit of emerge psychology manages to kind
of get lex luthor to sort of cure the
cancer on his own but in the middle of
all that
uh they're suddenly met by a
communication from diana saying like we
need your help right there's some girl
who's literally wrecking us
and so when lex luthor dawns his new
outfit in order to
you know travel with superman to face
off against wonder woman lex luthor's
sister pulls a gun on him
and then basically shoots him and then
uses a mother box and teleports both of
them directly to apocalypse
and so following that they're kind of
out of commission and so with grail
single-handedly taking out or at least
temporarily incapacitating
the entirety of the justice league she
in turn casts an inscription or
incantation
on the ground which is designed to
summon doomsday she also in turn
takes the ring of jessica cruz because
it's possessed by volthume
and uses the power within to basically
create a portal from this universe into
the earth 3 universe that summons the
anti-monitor and so at the moment what
she's done here is she's basically
brought anti-monitor to earth which is
what the anti-monitor wanted and then
she basically sends out an sos a beacon
that dark side will pick up on and then
dark side will travel to and so because
of that what you end up doing is you
switch over to scot-free and where scott
free was initially involved in a bit of
a conflict between kanto and lucina when
he
ultimately tracked down one of the women
named marina black of course not the one
they're hunting for he uses mother box
and then teleported them away along with
himself
and then when he arrived at his
destination he met the real marina black
the one that everybody's currently
hunting for now marina black as she's
given to us and as this explained here
she is in effect in amazon the idea
behind this is that marina black
basically states that at some point in
the past
she was the assassin of hippolyta the
mother of wonder woman right just her
own assassin but the idea behind the
amazons as they were originally
introduced and how they were supposed to
function was protectors of the earth
right that at some point they would kind
of go out into the world and they would
protect it the amazons under the
direction of hippolyta abandoned that
mission and instead they remained
confined to themyscira and just refused
to leave and so marina saw that as
a betrayal of what their original role
was supposed to be and so she ultimately
ended up encountering darkseid slept
with him and then produced a daughter
who we know is grilled the idea behind
this though was that she knew
something like that was going to happen
like she knew that at some point
darkseid was going to arrive here
and so the whole idea behind this dark
side war taking place
between you know mobius and and darkseid
and these guys is that she knew that
darkseid would eventually show up on
earth somewhere along the line and
conquer it and so in order to ensure
that would never happen
she produced her daughter grail who in
turn she drove to ally herself or at
least raised her so that she would ally
herself with mobius and then in turn try
to kill darkseid or try to leave the
dark side's death and so scott free
picks up on this and says this is crazy
right this is a crazy thing you're
talking about
because in a war between somebody like
mobius and somebody like darkseid
billions of people on the world are
going to die and the response of marina
is
you can't make an ammo without breaking
a few eggs right now of course scot-free
immediately rejects this
not because scot-free is a tried and
true hero his his
morality is a little murky depending on
what circumstance we're talking about
what era of comics even that we're
reading
but he ultimately shoots this down
because in his mind the ends do not
justify the means
and so this of course leads to marina
black realizing he's gonna rat her out
right he's gonna try to find a way to
defeat her she in turn tries to kill him
he uses his mother box and he basically
teleports out now switching back to
superman and lex luthor
there's a couple things that go on here
the first is that once they're here and
they're on apocalypse
superman does what he can to tend to the
wound of lex luthor from his gunshot
from his sister
the other thing is that once they
realize they're on apocalypse there's a
huge takeaway from this right now we'll
find out what that is here in a second
because while we're at apocalypse we
switch over to darkseid and and darkseid
is informed that one superman is here
and that two
uh his daughter has summoned his
presence and so for the most part
the idea of dark side is to focus on
mobius first that's really the biggest
threat
and his biggest concern with regards to
superman he almost kind of lets on this
thing that nobody else really seems to
know where you have steppenwolf who's
kind of like i mean why don't we just
like why don't you just let me destroy
superman right why don't i
go out there and take care of him or the
other guys go out there and take care of
him but the response of dark side is
no superman is small beans at this point
in time i'm not worried about the
kryptonian here on apocalypse
so he basically says tell the slaves who
exists out there on apocalypse that if
they're able to kill if one of them is
able to kill superman
they'll no longer have to work on
apocalypse they'll be spared any future
labor that they'll have to endure now
one thing to understand about the planet
of apocalypse
is it is a place of suffering and
torment that's true it's about as close
as you get to hell in dc comics without
actually going to hell itself which of
course is actually ruled by lucifer
morningstar
but there are people who dwell there
there are actual individuals there's a
society there right there's a society
you have different casts
in that society you have rebels who are
working to fight against darkseid you
don't really hear a lot about them
uh one because you don't really have any
comic books that focus exclusively on
that
and two the fact that dc doesn't really
focus on them is designed to kind of
point to the idea that darkseid rules
apocalypse with an iron fist
and no attempt by rebels is ever really
going to lead to their success
in toppling him right so it's almost
like dc's kind of saying they're not
important because they'll never succeed
anyway right so it's just kind of
designed to go towards the idea that
darkseid's just kind of this
person who cannot be defeated by anybody
on his own on his own turf right on his
own planet and so following that
you have the justice league who jump in
you know kind of jump back into the fray
again against grail
and then of course mobius basically
makes his move kind of quells the entire
conflict and is like we're done
because when that happens you have
metron who shows up here and metron's
just kind of like
this has to end right kind of trying to
broker the piece again and saying this
has to end this has to stop there's no
way this is going to work now of course
he also kind of tells the justice league
you cannot defeat mobius here right
there's no way for you to overcome the
power he possesses you're talking about
a being capable of wiping out
all life on entire worlds and like
ending entire universes right you're
just
not on that level and so he ultimately
whisks them away to the rock of eternity
which as most of you guys probably know
is where the wizard shazam resides where
shazam billy batson
got his powers and the reason why
they're here is because the rock of
eternity
is a place that for the most part cannot
really be detected by people like
darkseid or mobius or something like
that it's like a black hole right just
you can't really get into it you can't
really get out of it unless you know the
proper means and so what you end up
having is wonder woman using your lasso
of truth on metron and then saying how
do we end this right how do we stop this
conflict how do we come out on top you
know is there any way for us to defeat
the anti-monitor and the only off
the only option that metron can answer
is you have to take the mobius chair
from me it's the only way to do it and
so she does exactly that with the lasso
of truth wrapped around him she yanks
metron off the mobius chair now
understand
it's not as though metron and his mobius
chair are like
attractive magnets right it's not like
magnets that are attracted through
polarization like it's just this super
impossible
thing to do not at all it can be done
quite easily uh if you have the the
proper level of power i mean if you or i
ran up on metron and try to take him off
the mobius chair that's not gonna happen
right but the lasso of truth is one of
these artifacts that transcends
normal levels of power and it just sort
of allows her to ensnare
almost anybody and force them to tell
the truth there are limits to it but
it's actually been used on the spectre
in dc comics now the the idea of it
being used on the spectre is largely due
to the fact that the spectre is just so
incredibly powerful and and even then
he's just kind of bonded to a human host
so despite the power that he has it
affects more of the human side
than it does the godly side but we still
know that like it can affect
wildly powerful people but while she
does that ultimately you have
batman who dawns the mobius chair and
this is where you come across batman the
god of knowledge fills you guys who are
familiar with the concept but don't
really know where it originated from
and so right off the bat batman starts
asking a few questions to verify the
knowledge of the mobius chair right who
killed my parents
ping yes it's joe chill then he asked
the question what's the joker's true
name now
this is where the whole story of the
three jokers came from now keep in mind
this story was written back in like
2015. something along those lines 2014
2015 2016.
so during that period it was about four
or five years until we got an
actual answer from dc comics this right
this moment right here is the one that
intrigued
everybody for so long like we need to
know like what the name of the joker is
you know and then later on you actually
end up learning that there's three
jokers that exist out there
and trying to find the names of those
three jokers but for its part with
batman being on the mobius chair
initially the justice league tries to
talk him down and says hey look like
this
chair is a level of power that we
haven't really messed with before and
yes you're capable batman but this is
not something you can just do on your
own right i mean because batman puts off
all the indication that he's becoming
drunk with power that he's almost being
influenced by the mobius chair there's
almost a kind of arrogance that comes
with the power that he possesses but
ultimately batman shoots them all down
and it's just like no
like i'm not getting off the mobius
chair this mobius chair belongs to me
right like i am the only person who can
really
process all the knowledge that's
available or even use the mobius chair
adequately and so the result is that
there's
no way to get him off of that now the
justice league kind of resigns and
accepts this fact
because there's much bigger things to
worry about than whether or not batman's
going to get off the mobius chair and if
batman becomes a threat later on then
they'll in turn respond and there is
truth to the fact that there's much
bigger threats going on
because there are when we switch back
over to superman and and lex luthor
as they're there on the planet of
apocalypse all these slaves just come
pouring on them right and attacking them
all as best they can the problem with
this
is that superman's x-ray vision is fuzzy
it's not really working the way that
it's supposed to
and his initial thought is that there
must be some kind of lead in the air
that's designed to dilute his powers
because as we know
lead is the only only material that
superman cannot see through with his
x-ray vision and if there's lead in the
air
then it would mean that his x-ray vision
wouldn't be able to see clearly now of
course
lex luthor chimes in and says no like
there's you know there's cadmium and
there's polonium
and there's you know mercuric oxide but
there's very little lead in the
atmosphere and so it's kind of like okay
before they have a chance to figure out
what's going on
all these different slaves descend now
lex luthor and superman are
able to fight them off but in the
process superman is injured and that's
when lex luthor picks up on the fact
it's not anything like lead in the
atmosphere that keeps superman from
being able to see properly with his
x-ray vision
there's no sunlight here and because
there's no sunlight superman's powers
are draining and that's the thing to
understand about superman's abilities he
really
is a solar battery and so as long as you
keep that battery charged up you're
always going to be able to use it to its
full capacity the problem is that
once you take that battery off that
charger and then you just use that
battery's life up in its entirety
there's nothing left the battery's going
to be dead and that's how that works so
it's like water in a cup
that as superman strays away the further
away he is or the longer he's away from
the yellow sun
the more he uses his powers the more
those powers begin to disappear
right so if you were to just use his
power sparingly he would still be pretty
effective but those powers are draining
every time he uses them and so you can
assume he's at something like you know
50 power or something along those lines
but picking back up with the justice
league once scot-free meets back up with
the team
and then in turn all of them are
teleported back to where grail and
mobius are at
that's when the arrival of darkseid
comes and the truth about this is that
despite the justice league's power their
desire to step
in and and bring this conflict to an end
there's really nothing they can do
there's absolutely nothing they can
offer in this this battle all they can
really do is like fight against the
forces of grail
or the forces of of of you know mobius
or something like that but in terms of
actually stopping mobius and darkseid
they're powerless here right and that
was really their biggest fear was that
while they're here in seattle and while
all this stuff is popping off their
biggest fear was that the battle would
start to reach a tipping point where
there was nothing they could do to stop
it and so while you have mobius and dark
side facing off against each other
on apocalypse you have lex luthor doing
this final gambit where he looks at
superman and says okay
you are powered by solar energy these
solar pits here in apocalypse
they're solar fire right so i'm just
gonna throw you in it's the only thing
that i can think of so he literally
grabs superman
throws him in the pits of the of
apocalypse hoping that it'll basically
recharge his energies and bring him back
up
the problem with this is that when it
does he comes out completely corrupted
and twisted because the fire pits of
apocalypse have corrupting energy
they're designed to twist you out and to
mess you up and to cause all kinds of
problems they basically turn you into
your most evil self
and so kind of transitioning for a
second this is when we get the origin
more or less
of mobius right and this is where things
are completely were completely changed
recently
with scott snyder's run on dark nights
metal death metal his justice league run
all that kind of stuff
so the the original origin or the actual
origin of mobius as it's given to us
in this particular story is that mobius
was at one point in time
a science guy right he was an explorer
he simply wanted to understand the
universe and how all those different
things work and so he designed the
mobius chair to be this device that
could basically
catalog all the information he'd gained
as he gained it because
the the mind was simply just unincapable
of handling
all that information the result of this
was that during his explorations he
ended up encountering the anti-life
equation
that if free will exists in the main dc
universe which is the ability for you to
choose your own path in life to make
your own decisions the right ones the
wrong ones all that kind of stuff
and the anti-matter universe because
it's the opposite of the main dc
universe it has to be the opposite thing
and so the opposite of free will
is anti-life the ability to have your
will dominated by
others and so with mobius discovering
the anti-life he was basically
bonded to the anti-life equation and
lived his life as essentially a
destroyer the idea was that grail
approached him and effectively told him
if you kill darkseid you can free
yourself of the anti-life equation and
go back to being the person that you
were before
now of course again this has all been
changed that what scott snyder and all
those guys
did is basically established that in the
beginning there was simply perpetua the
creator of the multiverse and she was
the one who created the anti-monitor and
the monitor and the four drove worlds
and all that kind of new origin right so
the new origin as is told by snyder is
the current origin for the anti-monitor
now how you wrap those two things
together how you can bridge that gap is
really up to you right it's really your
own way of doing this if if you even
choose to at all it's entirely possible
you can just ignore that right because
what snyder did was basically come back
and render the entirety of dark side war
as a thing that doesn't really matter
anymore right it's not really relevant
none of the none of the origin stuff
that was given here is important anymore
but
the big takeaway from this is kind of
jumping back to the battle between the
anti-monitor
and uh and dark side because the
anti-monitor is the living embodiment of
the anti-life equation
when darkseid commits his most desperate
act in summoning the black racer which
is an aspect of death and those that
black racer touch
basically end up dying being taken to
the afterlife that when he summons it in
the ante monitor mobius uses his power
of the anti-life equation to dominate
the will of the black racer and then in
turn
bonds it to the flash barry allen
turning barry allen into the black racer
and so the black racer runs headlong
into dark side at the direction of
mobius and then kills darkseid and
darkseid
effectively dies right isca put it's the
end of the road for him but like this is
where we picked up this is where we
really ended last time
i think we did the tie-ins i'm not
entirely sure if we didn't let me know
um but i think we did all the tie-in
events because following this things pop
off
right things go nuts because now nobody
knows what to do with dark side being
dead and in fact the gods that give like
shazam his powers for example
are all panicking they're all bailing on
right like they're all basically bailing
out it's nuts right superman is like a
twisted corrupted
version of himself no one knows what to
do next there's nobody leading
apocalypse like it's probably the worst
case scenario for almost
anybody in the universe but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
you